there's an art to pulling the perfect
pint now there's a science to go with it
inside the walk-in cooler where the beer
kegs are stored all the beer that passes
through those Taps outside the quality
and the quantity is being measured by
these Peak flow meters the information
is then transferred to a box like this
via 3G or Wi-Fi ready to be analyzed by
the bar owner and Brewer using the
system says yoav Alon has helped to cut
waste and boost profits there sending us
a text message in the beginning of the
shift and tell us exactly what to do
take this beer from 9:00 to 10:00 offer
the second one in half
price oh it's 50% more profits 70% more
profit sometimes even 80% more profit
the real-time data and number crunching
come courtesy of Israeli startup Vice
bger the breweries know how many kegs
were shipped out of their factories we
tell them how those beer were
consumed uh on what hours what days uh
in what regions by providing them with
this data they can leverage it to a
better marketing methods better sales
methods and also monitor their beer
quality it can also throw up some
unexpected insights one of the most
surprising facts we found out is that
some of the beer is consumed when the
bars are actually closed so that's
probably the owner or the staff enjoying
some beer we find out that some brands
are doing better in certain days of the
week and certain times of of the night
for instance the lugger beer is consumed
in earlier hours than the strong alses
with so much beer data now available bar
owners and Brewers can be more targeted
with their promotions on the downside
they may also end up killing happy hour